how how long has it been since you've
been in this in this chair ah over two
years two years ago over two
years you you you're a staple here on
Skid Row yeah big
time it's changed a lot since you've
been here right yeah big time so this is
my third actual interview do you
remember my first one no so so many I I
didn't think so it's been a very long
time um
my neighbor uh who was a sex worker at
the time needed money and she had told
me um not very much but basically if I
came into did an interview that she
would get some money and I would too
yeah I kind of remember something and so
I was like okay um but when I came to
talk to you I didn't know anything about
you didn't know what this was about or
what I was doing exactly except for I
was just going to help my friend
and you actually told me no that you
weren't interested and I was pissed so I
was I was like wait what so I said
excuse me do you know who I am and I I
was like and you're like I no and I
don't care and I was like well come here
so I like pointed at some stuff in the
street and I'm like hey I painted this I
painted that I'll paint this [__] right
now and you're like chill out chill out
come on so so we did the interview but
um I was extremely honest and the first
thing that you asked me was how was your
home life how are you Bor I was not
prepared for that whatsoever and I
immediately said
everything and regretted it instantly
and so um a few weeks month later I see
you and I said hey uh I've actually
found your your um
platform but you you haven't posted the
interview and you're like yeah I don't
think I'm going to use it it was it
wasn't bad but it was uneventful and I
was so overwhelmingly happy because I
did not want my family to see that um I
said things about my home life that I
extremely regret because um I was raised
in a environment that was
not healthy at all mentally physically
emotionally it was not healthy but I was
born in the 70s and raised in the 9s and
you don't talk about those things
outside of your home and here I am on a
public platform telling the whole world
about my family's problems and I was
very happy that we didn't use it the
second one uh was the one that you aired
and
Man Mark I was drunk and delusional you
were I was um a lot of the people I
interview are
watching that
interview um was kind of tough I was
stumbling over my words and I just
rambled a lot and it didn't make a lot
of sense but the reason why in
retrospect Mark I didn't want you to
talk I was trying to prevent you from
talking because I knew you were going to
ask about the home life and that was
what I didn't like about our first
interview and so I tried to steer it uh
away from that and and I succeeded and
it did very well but the thing it is
looking at it Not only was I extremely
out of shape and overweight but my um
demeanor was just not conducive to my
character and so the whole world is now
seeing this and um I'm happy that now
this will be our third one but uh the
first one was almost 5 years ago and um
the second one I was wearing a shirt
that said skid R smoke
out and so many people were like uh
making comments about it like me being
on drugs and all this stuff which was
hilarious because I don't do drugs of
any kind but um that doesn't bother me
you know whatsoever but uh did you ever
use drugs oh yeah when I was in high
school but it just it wasn't for me you
know um I'm active and I play sports and
all that stuff is just like a kind of
hindrance to your health but I I don't
judge anybody you know um my friends do
but if they do I don't really hang out
with them you know it's just not my
thing but um one thing uh about my
friend who got me to come here
originally was um she was a really big
deal on your page and uh I watched one
of her interviews and was shocked um it
was very violent and the thing of it is
I've lived on the same Corner in Skid
Row for the better part of 10 years and
I'm a huge part of this community and I
love it but the thing of it is when you
watch these people's interview these are
my beautiful friends and neighbors Mark
and when I say this I'm not talking
about the cover of Vanity Fair let's
just be honest uh they're not going to
make it but um when I say that I mean
the most selfless acts of kindness from
people who have absolutely nothing to
give but yet they give the most is
commonplace in skid ow and you would
never know that if you didn't live here
there's three types of people in skid
R ones that work here ones that live
here and ones that are passing through
but there's a kind of a phrase or a
saying that says if you're in skid ow
you're selling something you're buying
something or you're up to something
which kind of rings true for a lot of
people not for me personally but uh for
the majority of people it's very easy to
uh stereotype people here so my friend
um was coming here regularly and sharing
her stories and became very popular and
kind of a staple on your show and then
um this was uh Russia or Riley right yes
yes and uh dear friend of mine I love
her uh so much um and the reason why
Mark specifically is uh I mentioned
selfless acts of kindness well
Riley came to my residence
I didn't even know she knew where I
lived I knew she knew the building I
lived in but she came to my residence on
Christmas and uh I'm all alone I'm hard
timeing it I don't have any family here
I don't talk to my family so I'm just
not having a great time and she knocks
on my door and says hey what are you
doing in your house on Christmas you
know they're giving away all these
things in the street I said yes but uh
I'm not interested and she says why not
and I I don't want to fight people for
food or clothes and you know but thank
you she comes back later
with a brand new Dickie jacket and like
a Christmas meal in a box and she gave
it to me and I couldn't believe it and
she left couldn't believe it she didn't
want anything from me she didn't ask me
for anything but in the streets that's
what everybody does hey can I get some
change hey can I borrow a dollar hey do
you got anything hey do you smoke and so
um this was not what I was prepared for
when I answered my door on Christmas
from somebody who lives in the street
who was a sex
worker my mind changed right then not
only about her specifically but about my
neighborhood in general and so um when
you came into the picture it was very
strange to me because uh here's a guy
who a lot of people are familiar with or
are talking about but they don't really
say too much and so I would see you you
know I live across the street from your
studio and when I would see you there's
a dog all white guy well to-do looking
man not intimidated or scared looking
which is very strange because uh
majority of people here who do not work
or live
here are always kind of like looking
over their shoulder they're just
uncomfortable Mark your sunbathing with
your shirt off and skid row and I just
thought man this guy's nuts but um after
uh this particular incident happened my
friend Riley her ttin burned down and
I'm watching this out my window of my
building and it's late at night and I'm
my heart is just breaking because I want
to run down there and try to do
something I don't know if she's home I
don't know if she's in the tent but I
know there's nothing I'm going to be
able to do um regardless of the
situation so um the next morning I go
down there and uh she tells me her um
candle fell over and cut her really bad
she had to go to the hospital
and
her ttin burned to the ground and uh I I
know because I watched it and um so I
gave her what little money that I had
and then
um she you know was able to
self-medicate and I was so happy that I
could facilitate that for her in a time
where uh she was just not doing well the
next day I had sold a couple things to
try to help her and I think I had like
40 or 50 bucks and I went and tried to
give it to her and she said uh no no no
that's okay um you helped me yesterday
and I'm not greedy and I said well I
know that but I want to help you and she
said well guess what I don't need
anything because um Mark took care of
everything and I was like who who and
she said Mark White soft underbelly and
I was like what do you mean she goes he
bought me a new tent he got me new
clothes he got me all these things and I
was like you've got to be kidding me but
for no reason Mark and when I say for no
reason there was no business transaction
there was there was no it was a selfless
act of kindness on your part but you
weren't benefiting from it and I thought
oh wow I was completely wrong about that
guy and I was happy to know that from
that day
forward I've been very very pleased that
you're a part of this community in
whatever aspect because what I've seen
over the
years is unbelievable um and what I mean
by that is that
um so many people come here with some
sort of uh
need or desire and I think majority of
times it's exploitive and it's
manipulative whether it's uh the people
that uh pass Stu out in the streets or
the missionaries everybody seems like
they're doing something for the
neighborhood but in reality it's all
about them they're recording themselves
why they're handing things to people
they don't ask anybody this is people's
homes mark this is their home they call
them homeless and that really upsets me
because the only person that I know in
the world that has a home with them 24/7
is a hermit crab and a turtle the second
you leave your house you're homeless
technically so everybody in the streets
is not homeless they have a home and
some of those homes whether it be a
cardboard box or a tent is cleaner than
the people who live inside so it's very
relative but I'm extremely sensitive to
the term homelessness because I don't
like it you can say whatever you want
and that's your opinion but um this is a
neighborhood full of people with homes
with pride with jobs with families and
just because um we've been alienated by
Society doesn't mean that we fit the
labels that people want to put us into
but at the same time we're not Saints
either so I totally get it but um
something that uh has been a major
turning point for me was just deciding
that um I want to be healthy mark my
father passed away a few years ago from
um alcoholism and I didn't even know
what happened so I got a call from my um
ex-wife and she informs me that my
father passed away and um didn't tell me
how or why and then a few weeks later
she calls me and tells me my stepdad
passed away and I thought damn you're
like the Grim Reaper when my mom call
dies or somebody else just don't call me
please um and uh so I've isolated myself
from my family for lots of reasons but a
lot of it is guilt you know I feel
terrible for the things that I did when
I was younger um and I just found a
place in downtown SK Road where I could
wallow in my pain I could get drunk I
could do graffiti do whatever I want and
no one's going to bother me no one's
going to stare at me I have horns on my
head nobody gives a [__]
um so it's very unique place but for me
when my father
died the attorney told me that um he
hung himself and I was like my dad
killed himself mark my dad's father
killed himself and so when he was very
young and it [__] up his whole life uh
his entire life my dad was just always
questioning himself you know maybe if I
was a better kid maybe if I didn't cry
my dad wouldn't kill himself and it just
it messed my dad up but I growing up
thought my dad was a loser you know um
he didn't go to college he didn't do
this you know and so I was ashamed of my
dad I'm not going to lie and so uh my
first video I spoke about these things
and he was still alive so I was
horrified thinking that he would see it
because I do love both of my
fathers um but I just decided you know
what
this [__] stops here I sto the
generational cycle of [__] suicide
and alcoholism now because I have five
kids and I could never imagine one of
them getting the phone call that I got
it's just a horrible [__] feeling so
um October
31st
2021 I was drinking tall cans on the
corner of 8 Street
and
spring it's a nice
area but it's Halloween and I'm drinking
I'm having fun I see some friends and uh
I'm
playing cordido music on the corner they
sing songs about me in Mexico I'm having
a good time you know and the cops roll
by and they see us and they stop and
they look at us and they wave and keep
going mark That's all the justification
I needed let's paint so now I'm painting
on the front of this brand new building
on in Spring and um some guy I've only
met one
time named bastard artist I I thought he
did graffiti maybe he's a photographer I
don't know because I don't know the guy
but uh I thought he was going to paint
with me and uh so he's filming well an
incident occurred where an individual
runs around the corner and assaults me
in the middle of me painting to my
surprise obviously and um so in my
defense of this unprovoked
attack
I'm painting and I sprayed him in the
face with a can of spray paint to try to
get him off of me well it worked
temporarily but this whole thing is on
video Mark it's on the corner of eth in
spring on a Main Street on a brand new
building but in my defense in my
rational alcohol induced uh mind I'm
only going to paint the windows not the
building nothing and they can just
scrape it off 20 bucks no harm no foul
and um
this person who is fighting me has on no
identifying marks uh he's an all black
so it's just some random do good or
citizen in my opinion come to find out
Mark he's a security guard from that
building and there's a bunch of other
security guards with him but it's but
they're all black and they have dogs
with them and so uh I'm trying to
explain to myself my situation to the
guy but once I sprayed him in the face
he wasn't trying to hear it
so uh
he backs me into the corner and I'm
telling him hey you know knock it off
well I headbutt him after spray painting
his face and then we falls into the
street and he's we're like wrestling
around in the ground and he gets me the
submission
move this guy could have snapped my arm
mark just broke my arm but he wasn't
really trying to hurt me which is the
weirdest
thing and I wasn't really trying to hurt
him but I was damn sure trying to get
away from the scene so um now it's like
a big public spectacle people are
commentating uh they're making jokes and
and Mark I'm going tell you the truth
not only did I had a good time but when
I watch the video it's funny as hell
except for the viral went video the
video went viral and they edited it you
don't see the beginning of it all you
see is me laying on the ground basically
screaming for help so it's not a
flattering video but I don't care I know
what
happened I have Contraband in my
backpack pack I cannot get caught with
this backpack I'm on bail for number
one and I'm a convicted felon I cannot
get caught with what's in my bag so I'm
yelling at this guy bastard to help
me but he can't really do anything
because of all the security guards but
you can't see in the frame so all these
people on the comments of this video
said this dude is a punk he left you
there he didn't help you not true he got
my backpack with the Contraband and left
took it to the car and came back that
dude saved my life nobody ever saw that
and um but that video
um went viral and a lot of people like
said oh this guy's these D guys career
is over um and graffiti they bad names
and um it was unfortunate but I never
saw it as a unfortunate situation I
thought it was hilarious uh because it
was it was funny to me but um as a
result of that my Instagram got hacked
twice and I lost my social media which
turned out to be a blessing a complete
blessing so from one week being 100%
dependent on social media for income to
a week later to having no contact I
don't work at a shop I don't have any
way to people to contact me so um
luckily for me I happened to get an
inheritance at that time for my father's
passing and I went to Portland Oregon to
visit a good friend of mine um
um Tristan gladstein rest in peace and
he was heavily into drugs at the time
and like I mentioned earlier that's not
my thing so I didn't really hang out
with them but I went there to hang out I
went there to live with this guy for a
month and do graffiti in Portland didn't
paint one time walked around downtown
with all this money stumbled in the
Pendleton
store the rest is history on that but
uh
so I decided uh to call a friend of mine
mine here and say you know what my
building in Skid
Row three people died in one day before
I left I've been in the same building
for seven years and it's hell on Earth
um it's across the street from your
studio you've been in that building Mark
it's not a good place no so um it just
became too much for me and I'm
running like a Speak Easy in a sense
so if you get tattooed by me during that
time it was incredible because you would
go to this roach infested rat bed bug
murderous ass
hotel to get tattooed but I would never
tell anybody they were coming to Skid
Row um I would actually say hey I have a
spot in the arts district um and I would
give them the address the day of because
I didn't want them to look up the
address and see that they're going to
come to skro because I know they're not
going to come but um I'm tattooing
people from around the world uh this
famous photographer estan Oriel from Los
Angeles um is sitting in my studio and
he goes
man 20 something 25 years ago this place
was a hell hole it still is and I
thought yeah you know but I turned it
into something beautiful but I lived
there and I slept on the floor and it
was a really tough life you know not
only dealing with uh drug dealers and
prostitutes and the police but I could
never rest in skid romark um you
you it's so much negative energy and
police sirens helicopters shootings dogs
attacking people um car crashes it just
it's even when you're sleeping you're
not sleeping because you're being
bombarded by all this noise and
negativity and it just affects you so
much that after s years I was compl
completely done like I just couldn't
bring myself to come back from Portland
to go back to that hell hole so um I
reached out to a good friend of mine and
um he allowed me to uh move to his place
in South
Pasadena very different if
you're wow yes uh I've never been to
South Pasadena have you beautiful it is
beautiful it's incredibly beautiful um
you get on the Gold Line and Little
Tokyo 15 20 minutes and drops me off
right down the street from my house but
Mark I had my own house I wasn't a
roommate and I wasn't living with an
individual I had my own house yard
backyard garage Garden it was
incredible but kind of
expensive really expensive so after a
few months I just realized you know I
can't keep doing this and um I told my
friend and he goes you know um we really
like uh having you here and um my wife
says uh you can
stay unbelievable I live in South
Pasadena rentree in my own house for a
year unbelievable but I still had my
place across the street here so I was
commuting from South Pasadena to Skid
road every day so weird and awkward um
on the train um but uh I wasn't doing
anything in skid Ro what were you coming
here for exactly
uh I would come water my plants draw a
little bit try to draw like and then go
back but after um a while I just decided
that uh my father's death was so
traumatizing to me that I'm just going
to change my life once and for all
permanently so I started working on
self-care never done it before um I
didn't go to rehab I didn't do 12 steps
um anything like that getting sober not
drinking was uh pretty challenging but
it was more than just getting sober it
was he Healthy Living eating well
exercising stop smoking stop drinking
and
um it was imperative for me to go
through that at that time but what I
realized is that uh South pasaden is
boring as [__] if if you're not retired
or have children or extremely wealthy
what are you doing in South Pasadena
Mark they're following me to the grocery
store on my bicycle the cops are making
up stories saying that I ran a red light
so they can search me because they think
that they've got some big timer and in
reality I'm literally just going to
Whole Foods to get an avocado but um so
I I moved back and so um luckily for me
I'm in a brand new spot no longer at
that horrible place that I was at um and
I'm very pleased about it but um what
really surprises me is that every time I
come down this
street I see you and it boggles my mind
why would Mark keep coming back here
haven't you accomplished what you wanted
I don't know how long that you can keep
doing this but for me as a
resident psychologically in energy it
kicked my ass to the point where I just
couldn't do it Mark I was there when
those three people passed away three
separate incidences in one day and the
police officer was leaving after the
first or second one and he made a
comment to the land lady at the time and
he says hey I'll see you on the next one
and I just thought
how
in Humane that that statement was at
that time was just not really uh the
best thing that he should have or could
have said at that
moment Mark he was back twice the same
day day so what I realized is he didn't
mean it in any malice and he wasn't
being a jerk it was just common
statement in skid Ro especially that
building that I was in some sometimes
people don't understand like people that
work
in uh like a police officer or or
doctors surgeons nurses all that kind of
stuff um people that work in trauma all
that sometimes making a joke about it
relieves the anxiety and the stress and
all the trauma of it so that you can
continue doing your work know and
sometimes I'll Snicker or chuckle at
some horrifying part of someone's story
it's not that I'm laughing at them I'm
I'm trying to relieve the anxiety and
the stress of of what they're saying but
sometimes the commenters will get all
worked up and oh you're laughing at
their their pain I'm not laughing at
their pain you don't get it I'm very
happy that you brought this up actually
understand I'm very happy you brought
this up because to carry on the
conversation and to deal with what's
being
told you either have to like start
crying or you start laughing yeah ex
yeah exactly but when I said I'm glad
you brought this up I mean um
particularly pertaining to about you uh
people ask me all the time um hey do you
know this person um and uh the fact that
they would ask me that not only does it
sparkk my interest but um I never let on
that I do I say uh why do you say that
because I'm very curious to hear what
this person's opinion is about you
because online like you mentioned a lot
of people make comments based off of
something they have no idea what they're
talking about they either see you
chuckle or they see something that they
may um view is that maybe Mark is being
insensitive or something of that nature
or he's just flought out rude or a
jerk if you've never been here if you
don't live here if you don't experience
this then not only do you not know what
you're talking about but Mark I spend
every day of my life in Skid Row trying
to
avoid what you do every day and I just
for the life of me can't understand how
anybody can do it as long as you have so
you're being bombarded with every
negative
thing that just sucks you down so the
fact that you keep coming back the fact
that your selfless acts of kindness um
have been going on for so long you're
not only a staple in this community but
um people depend on it they depend on
you they depend on your good nature they
depend on your channel but it's gotten
so freaking ridiculous ulous that
people's mentality is based off of
something that they saw on a YouTube
channel the hell are you talking about
there was a woman from Las Vegas who
after watching your channel for
years left her relationship drove down
here parked in the middle of the street
with everything she owns in front of
your spot and the hopes of catching you
so that you could save her and she's
telling me the story and and I'm saying
why do you think markk is going to save
you or help oh well he did this for this
person he did that I said do you
understand Mark is just a person he is
not a foundation he is not a charity if
and when he does help people that's all
the kindness of his heart but you're
seeing this on television or on YouTube
and you're making all these things in
your mind about what this man is going
to do for you or what he can do but do
you know that the amount of time and
money that he has spent down here is so
exponential you can never imagine it but
he doesn't have unlimited funds but the
big thing the reason why I said I'm glad
you brought the submark is because a lot
of people think that you are monetizing
off of these interviews and that you're
just making a ton of money and you're
exploiting all these people in St row
true oh this video got this many views
you know uh Mark should pay me more
money because uh my video did so well
and what they don't have any
understanding is the way that it really
works yeah I mean let me explain because
I I've I've been hearing this thousands
I know how it works but I want people to
hear it um first off I've been down here
since 2010 I used to have a studio on
Sixth Street then I moved to a studio on
Town and now I'm on Seventh Street
that's that's a better part of 15 years
Mark that's 13 14 years time and uh I've
been doing that since basically two
years ago when I finally monetized this
YouTube channel okay but in that time I
mean just in the last four and a half
years when I really started this YouTube
yoube Channel I've um I've done 8,000
interviews 8,000 365 days a year I don't
know how many days you take off but I
see you almost it comes about five a
day every single day every day I've
Haven been taking a day I took my first
day off in four and a half years just
this Christmas
Mark the emotional strain and toll um I
haven't really wanted to tell you this
but now I'll take the opportunity you
know when you see a president at the
begin of his presidency and then like a
few years into it he just just look shot
out and eyes puffy and I've seen this
happen to you oh yeah physically you
are strong as an ox you look good but
your face is telling a different story
yeah it beats the crap out of me it does
and not only can I see it but I spend
every day of my life trying to avoid
this and I live here you're coming here
with the intention of doing this five
times a day I couldn't do it five times
total so um the stories that you're um
hearing and the negativity that people
are dumping on you um doesn't happen to
me my friends and I hey how you doing
good to see you uh you got a cigarette
uh can I um get borrow your phone uh
these little interactions are really fun
and enjoyable yeah no I'm I'm diving
into the really meaty trauma of it all
and and and you know granted so not not
that I'm an angel or anything but you
know everyone has their faults but I
have been doing this for for no with no
income since 2010 that that's what I'm
getting at I I had an advertising
business I would do that on my free you
know that's what I did and when I had
free time I would come down here and
then four four and a half years ago I
really dove in and just started doing
this every day
um but for all those years up until two
years ago I didn't make a penny and yet
every day every day I'm down here I
spend roughly an average of
$1500 so do the math on that I and and
everybody's like so and and and on top
of that so now my channel is monetized
but of the top 50 videos on my channel
the most popular ones I would bet you 35
of them are
demonetized so that means like very few
of very few of my videos are making
money so specifically what I wanted to
address is that if an individual comes
on just like I am right
now we tell our story and then we leave
and we get ured for our time and it's a
very beneficial Pro process and there's
a finder fee involved with somebody who
brought you absolutely and uh the thing
of it is nobody in skid Roark is handing
out $100 bills besides you I have not
met one in 10 years not met a one but
you've been doing it for the better part
of five years but what that money does
is it gives the people of skid row a
chance to breathe a day off a day where
you don't have to do things that are
unconducive to your character just to
get some money I I I'm not big on
defending myself in the but I'm
defending myself here in this video but
I typic just let people think I'm the
devil or whatever so the people that
want to hate just want to hate and
that's and you know what I have a ton of
hate but let me let me address what you
just said when I'm giving money to a
drug addict what I'm doing rather than
supporting their habit is is giving
that's what you just said I'm relieving
the stress and Trauma of having to go
suck somebody's dick to get money for
that drug and just that statement alone
sounds har because they're going to get
the drug regardless there's nothing
that's going to stop but but your
statement alone right there sounds harsh
but this is the harsh [__] reality of
where we live and I just don't say it as
bluntly as you but that's exactly what's
going on here but um I have changed
myself in a dramatic way to where not
only am I not on social media period uh
which is a huge relief and a great um
thing for me personally because now I
get to focus on myself I have you seem
to be doing so much better than than
years past thank you I really appreciate
that and it and it's true but now I have
a new outlook on life I do photography
my stuff has been uh published I'm in
books I um have so many great things
going for me but now I give back to the
community that gave so much to me so do
you have your book here yes I have one
of my books um it is
uh I was published in
a
book called contagious culture culture
volume 3 this was put on
at the
um gallery that used to be around the
corner and and it burnt down and then
they moved it to Los
Angeles uh the Super Chief Gallery so
what was so unique about this is that
um I didn't
know this is my photo right here and
this the bottom one and it says skid
historian the mayor of Los Angeles miss
Karen bass Mark came to my studio in
skido a few months back to congratulate
me on my work as a
historian and I'm dumbfounded for
one how did you get my
number and what are you doing here and
she said um your photography and your
work in the community is um a very big
deal and that skid row and downtown
specifically is changing and your work
is not what she uh could cize as per
poverty porn um that you capture the
human element of Skid Row I was
dumbfounded dumbfounded this was not um
a meet and greet this was not a photo op
this is the mayor of Los Angeles
standing in my studio congratulating me
on something positive based off of
Photography and so um I wanted to show
you something
um that I actually made and um this is
my photography that I took here on the
streets of skid row but um you you have
thousands of these right oh I I have yes
thousands but um not too many really
people have ever seen them my work is
archived at the Los Angeles poverty
Department the skid History Museum but I
capture the human element of skidrow I
like to think so but um this is actually
for you oh wow and um thank you very
much you're welcome
oh look at that I'll let you I'll let
you read that but
um the things that I do now oh that's
sweet thank you you're very welcome and
um I just want to tell you that
uh I've never asked you for a single
thing um and the reason why is because
um I don't view you the same as other
people other people look at you like ATM
for drug money is the way that I look at
it and um they line up in front of your
studio and when I ride my bicycle past
here uh I see everybody with their hands
out and I just think to myself man this
is like my cousin uh my Primo Nito hey
uh in Spanish Nito means I
need every person in this line out here
is telling Mark I need I need I need and
yet here you are day after day whether
these people you're interviewing today
whether you're not interviewing them at
all whether you've interviewed them in
the past you continue to help people
financially and it just boggles my mind
because there's no reason for it well
there is it buys me the ability to do
what I do down here and not be somebody
who's
just exploiting or or or taking
advantage of these people or whatever
you know by by me helping absolutely the
community and dumping [__] I mean you do
the math on what I said earlier look how
that's that's a lot of numbers it is but
I don't think that
um it's buying Security in the sense we
hey here's some money please protect me
no this has happened organically through
your generosity and becoming a staple in
the community to now where not only
you're protected but the people around
you see you in a different light and
myself included so when somebody would
say Hey you know that guy Mark White
soft underbelly do you know that guy I
not
only do I have cards in my pocket with
my name on them from White soft
underbelly and uh there was a time where
I worked with you worked for you um
referring people to you I just decided
that uh you brought you brought me
Johnny who has 7even million views on my
channel you know not only Johnny but um
a whole bunch of great people great
people and um regardless of the numbers
I just wanted to show something that
wasn't skid Ro
and you have so much of it but it's only
because your location you know um but
your channel has grown and I think the
majority of um people just don't really
understand what this is and they look at
it like this is shock value this is
crazy um certain people want to be on
the
show but they all have an agenda they
want something for themselves they want
exposure they want Instagram likes they
want something but in reality your
reason for doing this is very meaningful
and has a huge purpose and I'm happy to
be a part of it
but I won't defend you Mark and the
reason why um not that I won't defend
you because that's not true be I should
take that back the majority of times I
let people speak their minds about you
because I want to see how far they're
willing to go and uh sometimes it's
really sad to me to hear people such
strong opinions about somebody they've
never met so after they go through all
this heated things about well did you
see this did you hear that did you know
he does this did you know and by the way
I know more intimately than anybody so
yes I do know but I don't let them know
that but what I what I say is uh wow
that's really strong
opinions how long have you known Mark
when did you meet him oh well I've never
met
him
wow that was some really harsh [__] that
you said based off any anytime you have
this kind of success a channel that's
grown to 5 million subscribers or
whatever getting this many views it's uh
you're going to get people hating on you
so it's just there's no way around it
anything and uh I can relate the reason
why um I mentioned the that video of me
getting in a fight because um it was
such a big deal in my graffiti career to
so many people that they claim that um
he got beat up he's this he's that and
you know one of the funniest things is
that uh that people like to say or used
to say about me
particularly two things he's not Mexican
and he's not from Los
Angeles that [__] would crack me up but
now the comment is always
bastard and I was yelling for this guy
named bastard to help me so whenever
they put that and by the way it was
almost three years ago and people put
bastard and I crack up because of shit's
hilarious to me cuz you were calling for
your you were calling for your friend
yes but no I didn't know the guy but you
knew you knew him as bastard right um
but I guess what I'm saying is I'm
empowered by knowing the truth and KN
what happens but the more that people
hate on you mark you must be doing
something right because is all these
people that dislike you or myself or
claim to that have never met
us somehow you watch everything we do so
I don't consider any of these people hey
they're just fans they're all fans
they're fan of your page they're fan of
my work but for me I'm very happy living
a quiet life now I do tons of volunteer
work um you given money to people in
Skid
Row I've been doing it since the day I
got here but I can't do it on a broad
scale and I'm really not in a position
to do it at all but um I have a huge
heart not as big as my bank account so I
decided I'm going to do it differently
now I work with harm reduction
um organizations here in skidrow I give
out drug supplies to people I make kits
uh but one thing that has um been so
empowering to me
or rewarding I think is a better word is
uh doing wound care so now I go around
the streets of skid R and people who
have very bad wounds I'm a medic and I
take care of their ws and so um there's
a man that lives on the street that I do
who's in his 70s in a
wheelchair and not only does he live
outside in a tent his neighbor 80 years
old and they're both intervenous drug
users but all his veins have collapsed
and he cannot shoot up anymore but Mark
he has softball size WBS on both arms
that are open absessed and pussing if
you look at it you almost want to vomit
but if you smell it it's rotten flesh
and it's pussing Mark this 70-year-old
man shoots up intervenous into those
open wombs every single day because
that's the only place that he can
hit I change his wombs change his
dressings and go by and check on them
every day and you will not [__]
believe it but they're healing they're
healing and um we got got him into to a
methodone Clinic got him a phone got him
the thing that he lost um but the thing
of it is um these selfless acts of
kindness that I've witnessed you and
Riley and so many other people in this
community doing for years is so
commonplace but it's easier to focus on
negativity it's easier to focus on
Mental Health it's easier to focus on
drugs but this is my home this is my
community and I'm super proud of skid ow
this uh is the official skid R City sign
that was painted and designed by General
Jeff rest in peace um and they changed
glattus Park to General Jeff Park
and there was a time Mark when people
used to ask me where I lived and uh I
wouldn't tell
them now I have La skid rad tattoo to my
entire head and back I wear my shirts
proudly um I have a name necklace like
uh the low riders that say skid R
California um because this is a
beautiful beautiful striving Community
full of so Mark there's businesses here
there's families here there's children
dogs people and they're all doing well
but when you focus on what you
see it's heartbreaking but Mark there's
the exact same [__] in Beverly Hills the
exact same [__] but they don't show it
it's behind closed doors it's behind a
nice marble facade it's behind Gates and
these well-to-do people are doing the
most horrible things but for me I'm not
only happy here in skid R but I'm very
happy um to not only know you but to
call you a friend and I've never asked
you anything um like hey uh can you help
me hey can you give me money can um you
pay my phone bill you're one of the few
that's never done that I've never done
it yeah five years and since we're on
this topic uh the money that you did
give me for the other interviews I gave
to the person that referred me not
because I wasn't in position of need but
because they needed it more in my
opinion and so um somebody says yeah but
that money that you gave somebody
they're just going to go and smoke
crack good I'm glad and they're like
what you're glad they're smoking crack
no I'm glad that they can go get their
medication that's what I'm glad you're
sitting here drinking coffee smoking
cigarettes eating sugar 10 different
types of drugs that the FDA or America
says is okay but this person is
self-medicating in a way that's
conducive to what they do because they
know how it's going to affect them my
body chemicals are different from theirs
which are different from yours but I
don't judge anybody yeah get getting a
drug addict to stop using their drug
isn't the solution right addressing the
mental health issue that's behind it is
the issue and that's why I do these
videos to show you how these stories
come about so that maybe we can prevent
it and it actually does work um not only
out of the 8,000 videos that you've done
do you help every single of those people
financially during that time do the math
I can't but for Ian I give everybody
money but weeks months years later
you're still helping those people
there's a specific person um on your
channel that gets a lot of attention
named Rebecca yeah and um
she uh is very eccentric and whenever I
see her in the
streets it's it's always an
ordeal she's exposing herself nudity and
she has male
genitalia and the fact that she's a man
who wants to be identified as a woman I
have no problem with and I call her and
refer to as a woman knowing that it's
she's not and her name because that's
her
choice but she gets excited when she
sees me and I'm excited to see her too
because this is a friend of mine from
Skid Row that's not in Skid Row but Mark
it's never a good situation
um so she asked me for a cigarette and I
say you know I don't smoke sweetheart
you know that and she goes I know can
you call Mark and I said sure I'll call
Mark and then when I call her when I
call Mark for her call you she
um says hey you know I need a phone and
you say I already got you a phone what
did you do with it and then she says oh
but I need this and but all the things
she's asking not only have you provided
before but you can continue to provide
and it blows my mind that you continue
to provide these things but every single
time I interact with her she is
completely belligerent exposing herself
and I have to prevent somebody from
attacking her physically every time yeah
there there's a serious mental health
problem behind all that drug use and and
but I also see behind all that mental
illness and drug use is a really
intelligent
kind compassionate genius and I see it
too but for the average person who's
walking by there's a man with a
beard partially dressed with genitalia
hanging out acting crazy acting crazy
and uh so this guy saw this and got very
upset and was in the middle of
assaulting he was going to drop kicker
in the nuts and I and I ran up and I
said hey hey stop stop stop stop hey
excuse me please don't do this um my
friend has mental illness and he goes
hey man you've been to prison and I was
like of course but what the [__] does
that got to do with anything and he's
like we don't play this [__] and I said
well good thing is neither one of us are
in prison anymore but second this person
has mental
illness nice to meet you bro just keep
moving and he goes nah [__] that there
his [__] dick is hanging out and if
my girl was with me right
now I would break this fool off and I
said well guess what your girl's not
here
nice to meet you man have a good day and
then he tried to sell me
meth stre the streets are rough yeah so
he he he just kept pushing I didn't buy
meth but what I did do is I hung out
with Rebecca uh we ate cake that she had
marked she got this cake out of a trash
and she's eating it but she's she
offered me some I'm not going to get
disgusted and be like no I don't want
any of your cake uh it looked good I
don't personally eat all the trash but
hey so I shared some of her cake and she
asked me to play her a song so I'm
playing a song on the side of the road
on your phone on my phone dancing eating
cake with somebody that is completely
belligerent and out of their mind and it
was the highlight of my day so for
people who don't understand mental
illness and they don't understand that
crazy [__] um guess what I don't either
but I'm compassionate and I'm not
judging her I'm not making any um
judgments all I hope is that the next
time I see her she remembers my name and
whether she does or doesn't is
completely irrelevant but it's because
I'm a part of the community that
celebrates
individuality it
art so many wonderful things here Mark
you know we have Community Gardens here
we have Parks and Recreation we have so
many beautiful things here in Skid Row
but people just focus on one little
thing and it's very easy to do and um I
just uh am very happy not to be a part
of it um this is a major thing for me is
I've seen two videos that you've done
one with um another guy who has a
YouTube channel and he walked around
Peter S
yes that one was my favorite because you
showed Skid Row you walked the streets
of skid R and see note uh was with you
and kind of like um ad libbing certain
things or uh just kind of making sure
people didn't SN snatch p
phone but you can't film
here everybody knows that you cannot
film in Skid Row Mark people drive down
the streets holding their phone out the
window they blow the red light because
they don't want to stop because people
are going to run against their car but
if you were to walk through skid row
with a camera you are going to get
attacked and the reason why
is because people don't want to be
showing their illegal activity for
number one but we don't want our
families or friends or relatives to see
us in a compromised position and just
because we're outside or in the streets
this is still our
home so I would never walk up into
somebody's home or their front yard and
just start filming them and their family
oh wow look that chick's got a fat ass
and just start filming her but there's
somebody here who's completely nude who
might be taking a bath who might be
changing who might not have any clothes
or in Rebecca's position might just be a
mental health crisis but these strangers
are taking photos of these people and
putting it on Instagram putting on thing
uh making books about this having art
shows and it's disgusting to me you're
not doing any of those things and
neither am I um but sometimes I
do but the thing of it is what's
different about what about that
statement is I think that you've earned
the right to show what what's actually
going on and it's not exploitive if
that's what you're doing the spirit
behind what I'm doing is to create
awareness of what's going on thank you
Mark um because that that's that's the
phrase that's been on the tip of my
tongue is um I don't Advocate drug use
but I work for harm reduction so you
give people drug supplies but you don't
and no I do not but what I do is I'm
hoping that if somebody's going to do
that they can do it in a clean manner
where they harm themselves the least and
other people so the second video that I
saw you do that I like so much was you
just walking around and driving around
skid row no talking and one of the most
powerful parts of that entire thing is
you just did head
shots of a bunch of indiv individuals I
was one of them but
um it brought me to
tears and nobody's talking nobody's
saying anything
but the power I have chills Mark um you
can't fake that stuff and um that
emotion that I saw it came across in
your video you did it you got it you
[__] captured it because in this
studio it's um if you do prison time if
you watch a movie about a documentary
about skid R these things are not
conducive to reality and you just can't
get the P sitting in a holding tank for
days hours however long is unbelievably
hard to describe on Cinema and they just
oh guy goes to jail next scene 30 years
later he's getting
out you can do 8,000 videos Mark 880,000
videos and it just does
not paint the picture of skid row until
you're out there so that video that I'm
describing the second one uh you got a
lot of negativity on the comments oh
he's driving around you know people are
hollering at him he's you know and I
just thought man these people are so
ignorant and the thing of it is the
definition of ignorance is lack of
knowledge I didn't say they're stupid I
said they're ignorant about what they
were going who this guy is in the
community the work that you've done that
you continue to do your selfless acts of
kindness all these things are things
that people don't even understand and my
dear friend Riley somehow
now doesn't like you because either a
statement that you made to her or after
weeks or months of years of you
contributing to
her you didn't one time and she got mad
and got offended or maybe you snapped at
her and the r the rumor is I'm making so
much money off everybody that's what I
was think and if you're if you're
uninformed then then that looks like oh
he's making lots of money so if I come
on here and I do a video right now and
this video gets uh a bunch of views and
a bunch of following 100,000 views
100,000 views but let's it's going to
let's just say it gets a couple million
now what people in Skid Row or other
people think is oh Mark just made a ton
of money off that person he should help
that person so now this person comes
back and is like hey you made a lot of
money off me you should hook me up you
should break me off they don't
understand all the expense that goes
into this too not only all the expense
but the I think every one of those
videos that I was scribing got
demonetized yeah so you didn't make a
dime but that person doesn't know that
and if you told them that they don't
believe you because they look at this
thing that's why there's so much
hate right and for me um that's why I
don't say anything because the hate is
so strong I would rather know the truth
instead of trying to be an advocate for
this Channel or for you personally
you've been here for 5 years I think
you're doing an amazing job but the fact
that you're still here to me tells a TA
to tape this wasn't somebody Fly by
Night somebody that came in here to
exploit people make money and take off
and um you mentioned to me that uh Joe
Rogan said to you after being on his
program Mark if you really want to ruin
your day go read the
comments and um yeah yeah Jo Joe said
the best advice is just just never read
the comments so I'm gonna try to stick
to that if this interview uh you end up
using this interview that comes on your
channel I'm not going to read the
comments simply because because um I
really know the truth and uh it was a
pleasure my friend all right man you're
amazing thank you I'm glad you're doing
better yeah very
much